[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va passer toutes les
missions d'aujourd'hui avec marcel
gaucher historien et philosophe qui
publie deux livres la droite et la
gauche l'histoire d'un destin histoire
et destin chez gallimard et bakr on les
leçons d'un échec chez stock mais
commençons pas l'image que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque
marcel gaucher j'ai cru reconnaître la
marseillaise de rudes
endommagés on s'en souvient c'est cette
mutilation là qui résumera dans les
livres d'histoire
l'épisode des gilets jaunes et qui en
illustrent le caractère la gravité c'est
pour ça que cette image a fait le tour
du monde c'est tout à fait étonnant de
voir comment elle a été reprise dans la
presse mondiale mme dans la presse
magazine elle
et concentre quelque chose qui veut dire
qu ont touché au coeur de ce qui fait
l'héritage républicain français ce n'est
pas rien et pourtant ce n'est qu'une
image dont on peut discuter à l'infini
la signification et qui sera réparé
depuis mai bien entendu
elle n'avait qu'un trou mais cette
mutilation a eu une portée qui montre
bien quelque chose de très profond qui
se passe dans notre société
c'est le sein de la primauté finalement
du symbole sur la signification exacte
du point de vue d'un historia bhl
étroitement au factuel c'est un
épiphénomène mais ce qui compte c'est le
symbole beaucoup plus que le fait
lui-même qui n'est que le produit d'une
émeute qui tourne plus ou moins bien
dans sur les champs-elysées mais la
portée du symbole va très au delà de et
c'est la portée du symbole qui restera
au delà de l'aspect strictement
matérielles des événements on en
reparlera pas seulement des gilet jaune
puisque vous vous portez une analyse
très fine à mon avis une des meilleures
qu'on avait pu produire sur ce mouvement
dans le deuxième livre dont nous allons
parler et mais commençons
[Musique]
et commençons par la droite et la gauche
histoire et destin stade longue article
paru il ya 30 ans dans le troisième tome
des lieux de mémoire la série d'ouvragés
dirigée par pierre nora vous l'avez
augmenté d'une postface rédigé
aujourd'hui où vous répondez à la
question si souvent posée ce clivage
gauche droite at-il encore un sens oui
d'après vous couriez sa pérennité 1 je
crois à sa capacité de signifier quelque
chose pour les acteurs politiques ce qui
fait croire à sa disparition c'est qu'il
fonctionne beaucoup moins bien sur le
terrain électoral
il n'est plus mobilisateur il ne permet
pas vraiment aux citoyens de se situer
par rapport à l'offre politique ça de ce
côté-là il a beaucoup perdu beaucoup de
gens votent à droite pour des raisons de
gauche beaucoup votre vote a goal pour
des raisons de droite tourné dans le
brouillage mais à titre individuel la
plupart des personnes continuent
d'accepter de se ranger dans cette
dichotomie c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre alors même qu' elle ne les
mobilise plus du point de vue électoral
des dix plus leur vote oui exactement
mais vous raconter bien comme ancêtre ce
clivage droite gauche né en france s'est
répandue au fond dans toute l'europe et
même dans le monde d'une certaine
manière son vrai mystère parce que il
est tellement français au départ dans sa
manière de se définir que on ne comprend
pas bien a priori les raisons qu'il a pu
avoir de devenir une sorte d'emblème
démocratique c'est le langage de la
politique que tout le monde comprend à
l'échelle planétaire pour y compris à
l'intérieur deux partis totalitaires ou
qui comportent toujours gauche à droite
mais même en régime de parti unique on
sait ce que veut dire la droite et la
gauche
est bien évidemment le fait que ce soit
des termes vagues à souhait puisqu'il ne
désigne que des positions spatiale oui
au départ c'est à l'assemblée ce qu'ils
soient zia gauche ceux qui sont assis à
droite point là mais ça va devenir le
comment dire la catégorie central de la
politique démocratique et la première
question que les gens se posent pour
déchiffrer une orientation dans un
système de représentatif c'est ça qui
est extraordinaire c'est comment on est
passé de quelque chose de très locale
presque folklorique un langage universel
de la politique et l or pour vous
emmanuel macron il est de droite où il
est de gauche l'habileté des manuels
macron a été de comprendre la situation
de brouillage de ce clivage
l'intelligence de plus de ne pas dire
ceci va je ne veux rien dire ils
l'assument mais il se dit est de droite
et de gauche c'est beaucoup plus malin
que les prédécesseurs souvent à droite
d'ailleurs qui disait monsieur fini tout
ça ça n'a jamais voulu rien dire
d'ailleurs est la preuve en est c'est
que nous allons faire une politique est
au dessus de ce clivage alors après on
peut apprécier
ce moment c'est une des questions posées
en permanence à propos de la politique
d' emmanuel macron est ce une politique
de droite est politique de wolf et c'est
peut-être les deux successivement eh
bien ça s'appelle en même temps d'une
certaine manière alors passons à votre
livre le plus important ce début de
campagne présidentielle car il est
bouillonnant d'actualité il s'intitule
macron les leçons d'un déchet qu'il
paraît chez stock c'est la suite de
comprendre le malheur français que vous
aviez publié en 2016 et cette fois
encore c'est sous forme d'entretiens
avec eric collomb et françois et zouvi
disons le tout de suite ça n'a rien à
voir avec le traître et le néant le
livre de dab et l'homme qui caracole en
tête des ventes ce n'est pas un livre de
divertissement politique rempli
d'anecdotes et psychologisant s'éteint
c'est un livre d'historien et de
philosophes un livre fondamental à mon
avis qui devrait être lu par tous ceux
qui rêvent aujourd'hui de devenir
président de la république puisque vous
y expliquer pourquoi emmanuel macron qui
avait plutôt bien compris ce que vous
appelez le malheur français n'est pas
parvenu à y remédier alors est-ce que
vous pouvez d'abord nous dire ce que
vous entendez par malheur français
marcel gaucher oui en effet c'est une
notion qui est a priori vague mais qui
en fait dans le cas français désigne
quelque chose d'assez près si c'est le
malaise d'un pays dont l'héritage
historique est ce qu'on appelle le
modèle qui est un modèle venu du fond de
l'histoire
se trouve
déstabilisée par le rapport à un monde
mondialisé qui fonctionne au rebours de
ce modèle français sur tous les plans on
peut prendre le critère le plus simple
la place de l'état la mondialisation
néolibérale
minimise la part de l'état au profit du
libre échange et de l'ouverture des
sociétés les unes sur les autres pour
les français c'est quelque chose qui
heurte directement ce qui a été la
gloire histoire depuis des siècles
bien entendu que les français sont dans
la mondialisation
mais ils y sont malheureux ce n'est pas
la manière dont ils voudraient que leur
modèle politique fonctionne en ce sens
là le malheur c'est le sentiment d'être
en quelque sorte mis de côté par le
mouvement du monde pour un pays qui
s'est pensée qui a été réellement dont
sur tous les plans à l'avant-garde du
monde que ce soit sur le plan politique
par révolution française et ses suites
que ce soit sur le plan culturel très
important pour les français y compris
les français les plus incultes cela n'a
aucun rapport y compris sur le plan
scientifique et sur le plan
technologique sur plan industriel on n'a
jamais été tout à fait heureux mais on
avait les ingénieurs qu'il faisait rêver
le monde entier par leurs performances
techniques le dernier épisode vraiment
remarquable dont jean c'est le concorde
l'avion le plus sophistiqué qu'on ait
jamais construit mais qui n'a pas fait
un succès économique que fulgurant
oui on peut dire ça donc emmanuel macron
on a remédié en rien aux malheurs
français au fond vous dites que le pays
est toujours au même point alors que ils
voulaient le transformer un c'était la
promesse
l'ambition était même remarquable et le
langage pour l'exprimer a sonné assez
juste pour provoquer un phénomène qu'on
n'attendait pas c'est la démolition
l'atomisation du système des partis en
place les coûts des partis qu'on
appelait le gouvernement dont on voit
qu'ils ont irrémédiablement
baissé en crédibilité dans l'opinion au
profil macron et donc il a saisi où il a
su lui une soeur restera justement je
n'entre pas du tout dans des
considérations psychologiques
je me contente d'observer les faits il a
donné le sentiment qu'il avait compris
ce dont il s'agit c'est qu'il y compris
sur le plan du style politique
l'écoutent de la société la volonté de
coller ou à la préoccupation immédiate
des citoyens et le fait qu'on est obligé
de constater ces camps ou bien c'était
une illusion ou bien ça a été une
impuissance de sa part qu on peut
interroger il n'a absolument pas répondu
à la promesse dont il avait su que faire
un système politique ce qui est pas
banal et une des raisons pour lesquelles
il n'y est pas parvenu vous l'expliquer
c'est que la vème république pour
fonctionner impliqué des partis
politiques puissants et que la
révolution des manuels mâcon a été
justement de détruire c'est enfin de les
réduire à peau de chagrin ces partis
politiques puissants le commencer par
son propre parti
il n'ya pas retenez pas au parti
socialiste à vous parler de la
république en marche il y là on a un
sens porté une logique de la vème
république
à son extrémité il n'y a plus que le
président de la république qui à la
limite pourrait dire que le parlement en
cause dans son coin parce qu'on va pas
le supprimer ça ferait mauvais effet
mais ça n'a aucune importance il est là
pour voter ce qu'on lui dit voter et ils
ne discutent pas et finalement on lit se
révèle
contre d'une certaine manière ce que
beaucoup d'observateurs croyaient ce
qu'effectivement le parlement et abc il
compte pas c'est faux il a une fonction
toujours essentiel dans l'esprit des
gens c'est de mettre sur la table les
options en présence quand il ya un choix
politique à effectuer et de permettre
par la discussion qui s'installe entre
des parties solides capable d'argumenter
leurs positions pour permettre de
comprendre exactement entre quoi et quoi
il s'agit de trancher et oui en général
c'est dans le ce débat là qu'on comprend
où est le problème général d'ailleurs et
êtes-vous dit il à il a renouvelé le
parlement à 75 % ce qui est exquis et un
travail à blain emmanuel macron mais il
affaiblit le parlement n'a pas été le
lieu de la délibération publique et est
au fond aucune personnalité ne s'y est
révélé à part peut-être autour de la
france à 1 soumise avec françois ruffin
ou adrien quoi tornade mais au tour de
manuel macron absolument personne alors
que c'était une des grandes promesses de
son de sa campagne qui était de faire
émerger la société civile dans la
politique une voix dissonante par
rapport à une politique professionnelle
qui était effectivement très ronronnante
on s'est dit nous allons avoir une voix
fraîche nouvelles originales
capables de faire remonter les attentes
collective et on n'a vu ni rien comme
thème ni personne comme individualités
portant une que ce soit la
représentation d'un secteur
professionnel ou des aspirations
collectives particulière le/la
république en marche et un nom parti qui
n'existe que dans la dévotion à une
personne sans avoir su ou où tu joues il
ya peut-être je tendrais à penser qu'il
ya une grosse erreur de casting née en
partie de l'improvisation la hâte la
ferme il fallait faire vite et donc en
fait on a pris non pas la société civile
mais les deux groupes 2e 3e 4e couteaux
des parties déjà en place et finalement
on a tous la même chose en moins bien
mais vous dites là où c'est le plus
grave sans doute c'est que bagnols macro
s'est retrouvé sans relais dans le pays
oui c'est là où on voit ce que signifie
un système de parti c'est en réalité
l'intermédiaire obligatoire entre le
sommet du pouvoir et la société à sa
base ou
avec tous les défauts qu'on peut trouver
à ces systèmes plus ou moins
notabiliaires il joue un rôle de
courroie transmission comme on disait
dans une autre époque avec le pays ils
sont à la fois capable de faire remonter
un état d'esprit des citoyens est
capable de rendre d'expliquer sur le
terrain des gens qui ne re qui ne sont
pas perçus par les citoyens de base
comme représentatifs issa même temps
leur nom ce qu'on a pu vérifier par des
enquêtes beaucoup de français ne savent
pas qu'il ya des mondes du député qu'il
est supposé les représenter il s'adresse
très peu à eux et ses députés n'ont
aucune autorité auprès des citoyens pour
faire pour défendre les orientations du
gouvernement les expliquer ou dans
l'opposition
man qui
laminait aucune capacité de porter une
parole contraire on a une onde un
effacement de ce set france rod de la
base qui ne compte plus en politique il
ya du coup un exercice qui n'est pas
simplement solitaire du pouvoir parce
qu'on peut être avoir un exercice
solitaire du pouvoir dans une société
qui se défend mais on a un silence de la
société avec une parole présidentielle
qui occupe tout l'espace d'où le
caractère dites-vous hâtif ou
superficielle de l'appréciation des
situations et on l'a vu par exemple avec
deux événements qui ont eu leur
importance le mouvement des villes et
jaune par exemple là il ya la situation
est très mal là on voit emmanuel macron
on va envoyer le manuel maquereau au
milieu du grand débat
mais avant le grand débat il ya eu ça il
ya eu tous ces gens dans les rues qui
n'avait pas du tout été prévu non c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire on n'avait
jamais vu un mouvement social de ce
genre les mouvements sociaux en général
sont suscités par des organisations le
côté extraordinaire des gilets jaunes
pour commencer c'est qui tient le
l'offre technologique en ce sens les
réseaux sociaux sur internet n'est qu'il
n'y avait pas de gilet jaune parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de moyens de constituer
une offre
qui soit suffisamment mobilisatrice pour
faire descendre les gens sur les ronds
points mais on a eu un mouvement de la
société là pour le coup la société
civile elle était là et on l'attendait
pas puisque rien dans les navets permet
d'anticiper la protestation qui s'est
exprimé sur une mesure qui est
probablement venu d'en haut était tout à
fait marginale une hausse motivée en
plus par motifs écologiques
absolument sacré sur le carburant est
simplement il l'analyse n'avait pas du
tout été fait de ce que ça signifiait
pour les français de base pour les
citoyens de obligés d'aller à leur
travail
alors qu'on disait qu'on valoriser le
travail etc ont pénalisé la possibilité
travail et par la hausse du prix des
carburants on l'a vu aussi
au moment de l'épidémie de vide à
plusieurs reprises on a vu le décalage
qui pouvaient exister entre une
administration des dirigeants est un
pays réel on voyait bien que là non plus
il n'y avait plus de relais non le cmem
au fond sur ce point que la chose est la
plus flagrante parce que parler gilet
jaune c'est un mouvement protestataire
qui donc a sa logique propre dépendant
de celle de pouvoir dans le cas de duke
aux ide sa gestion c'était la confiance
qu'on peut porter un système
institutionnel pour proposer les
meilleures mesures en phase avec ce qui
s'impose à tout un chacun comme cadre
rationnel pour se battre contre
l'épidémie là donc on a vu une
incompréhension
doublement meurtrière pour le moral des
français 1 ils croyaient encore un peu
qu'ils avaient un état qui marche et ils
ont vu que il était pour le moins
bringuebalant et 2 nous vivions sur
l'image avantageuse que nous avions le
meilleur système de santé du monde est
alors en dépit des protestations que les
agents de ce système
manifestaient depuis des mois et on
s'est aperçu qu'on était dans la
catégorie disons donc en queue du
peloton
dans les pays les plus riches bien
entendu aux fins d'un dpi vous voyez
constamment chez emmanuel macron l'excès
de confiance
dans les recettes de la technocratie
oui il s'est même étrange chez quelqu'un
qui n'ait qui n'a pas la fibre
technocratique ne serait ce que par son
style très personnel la technocratie c1
personnelle c'est la confiance dans les
règles lui fait confiance avant tout à
son intuition personnelle est assez
décision singulière donc ce n'est pas un
technocrate dans l'âme si je puis dire
même s'il est passé par tout le cursus
est cependant il a une espèce de naïveté
qui est étrange c'est un homme très aux
calculateurs manifestement très
tacticien il fait confiance dans des
mesures dont l'application lui échappe
totalement c'est là où il ya aussi on
voit que il est dans le malheur français
à sa façon c'est qu'ils ne voient pas
que l'appareil qu'ils croient commandés
ne répond plus ou n'est plus en état de
répondre aussi de manière aussi fiable
qu qu'autrefois puisque vous parlez
d'une technocratie qu'il se croit
éclairé alors qu'elle n'est que suiviste
elle a été éclairée grassi à une époque
junior république même sous le général
de gaulle elle était de sa manière
éclairée aujourd'hui vous dit qu'elle
n'est plus que suiviste
précisément on retient qu'on revient au
malheur français cette technocratie est
suivi par rapport à la recette
internationale standard ils ont le la
technocratie golis ou la technocratie la
de la reconstruction qui a suivi la
libération elle était indépendante
il y avait des têtes fortes têtes qui
réfléchissait avec l'idée d'ailleurs de
définir des modèles originaux
le nous sommes passés sur la défensive
et notre technocratie au tout premier
chef aux vaches et par l'onglet si je
puis dire
et elle parle européen est le même et
vous êtes leur part sont propres à sa
part un an
elle croit à ce qu'elle a pris elle à ce
qu'elle a appris à l'école et à l'école
relais effectivement une semaine
du gatt international qui est supposé
porter les bonnes recettes et quand en
plus quand on est un imitateur on n'est
jamais aussi bon que l'original donc
elle est faible dans l'imitation et le
suivisme ce qui ajoute encore une
difficulté supplémentaire là on est au
coeur du malheur français c'est à dire
la perte d'initiative de capacité à se
dire le monde est comme il est on va
définir notre joie à nous là dedans mais
il ya aussi on voit bien vous le dites
la réforme des retraites par exemple qui
était capitale pour emmanuel macron
c'était un emblème elle a été bâclée oui
est étrangement sans qu'on comprenne
pourquoi
on a eu un nombre de réunions
préparatoires pour nous avec lesquels on
nous bassine est régulièrement ça doit
être du sérieux arriverez revoit un
texte qui était fait en réalité pour
éviter toutes les difficultés en
espérant qu'on les voit pas mais les
retraites c'est du sérieux les choses
sont bien de près le texte et on a vu
tous les trous dans la raquette qui ont
fini par anéantir le projet moi ce qui
m'a le plus frappé puis je crois qu'on
avait parlé puisque vous étiez venu dans
cette émission juste après le
confinement
marcel gaucher c'est le moment du
deuxième reconfirme ans on est en
octobre et ce qui est fascinant c'est
qu'on a l'impression que personne au
gouvernement personnes dans
l'administration n'avait pensé ce
deuxième confinement pourtant on avait
vécu dans l'impréparation et
l'improvisation le premier et puis après
y'a l'été et on a l'impression que
personne ne s'est assis pour se dire
alors que tous les scientifiques
disaient attention ça va redémarrer dès
le 3 mai d'autres organisent au genou on
a l'impression que personne ne s'émeut
assis à une table pour prévoir ce qu'on
allait faire en mieux par rapport à la
première fois et on l'a vu avec les les
rayons fermés des hypermarchés que
personne n'avait prévu le les airs mais
d'une manière à berry avec
l'interdiction d'acheter des piges à bac
3 en mai la possibilité d'acheter des
pyjamas deux ans ce fameux tweet de
michel edouard leclerc
bull plus qu'ironique bas le voilà
voilà là on a l'impression que c'est la
faillite de la bureaucratie française
oui de
une bureaucratie ne s'est pas improvisé
mais on ne va pas le lui reprocher c'est
ça tient au système de règles auxquelles
elle obéit mais on peut lui demander de
réfléchir en amont si je criais on a
l'impression que les vacances étaient
passés par là que l'idée qu'ils puissent
poser des problèmes sérieux avaient
disparu des cervelles ça si on est
méchant si on est plus réaliste je dirai
tout simplement que le la
l'impréparation venait d'en haut et
c'est plus grave c'est à dire qu'il n'ya
pas d' on a un peu l'impression d'un
état où en dépit de cette omniprésence
d'une parole présidentielle ou à cause
d'elle il n'y a pas de vraie
commandement on n'est pas dans un
système organisé véritablement et d'où
l'impression de désordre qui affecte
profondément beaucoup de français qui
sont râleurs parce qu'ils comptent sur
le fait qu est une autorité solidement
constitué qui tient tout le monde
ensemble mais on dirait aussi d'après ce
que vous dites qu'au fond emmanuel
macron avait des ambitions mais qui
n'avait pas les moyens de ses ambitions
pas intellectuellement pas politiquement
il n'avait pas les moyens de ses
ambitions parce qu'au fond l'état
l'administration ne sont plus ce qu'ils
étaient
il ya deux choses d'une part le facteur
que vous dit certainement mais aussi en
amont une insuffisance criante du
diagnostic qui l'aurait qui était assez
flagrant d la campagne de 2017 mais
qu'il aurait pu compenser c'est ce qu'il
promettait c'est ce qu'il faisait naître
chez beaucoup de gens un espoir
raisonnable c'est qu'il allait écouter
ce qu'ils allaient remonter du terrain
et donc ajuster en permanence on compte
encore de l'épidémie du comme il aurait
pu le faire beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
gens qu'il y avait deux d'excellentes
idées qui auraient pu améliorer très
vite les choses si on les avait laissé
faire les exemples pullulent à 2 à tous
les niveaux qu'ils s'agisse
d'équipements qu'ils s'agissent de
manière d'organiser les hôpitaux qu'ils
s'agissent de faire appel aux services
privés de spitalier il y avait eu
quantité de choses qui précisément n'ont
pas remonté parce que ils n'avaient pas
creuser vraiment les dossiers et que une
fois au pouvoir
la machine prend le dessus et ils ont
cessé de réfléchir et il n'avait pas de
parti pour porter sa et d'autre part en
effet le nous voyons bien que c'est le
c'est un des problèmes majeurs du pays
le système public est devenu
dysfonctionnel pour des raisons qu'il
faut essayer de comprendre on fait une
pause marcel gaucher on y revient juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec marcel gaucher
historien et philosophe qui publie
macron les leçons d'un échec aux
éditions stock parmi les leçons de cet
échec vous montrez et c'est exactement
la suite de ce que nous disions juste
avant la pause que emmanuel macron avait
été élu en marchant est la rencontre des
français dans un rapport d'horizontalité
et auquel a succédé une fois élu une
verticalité de plus en plus vertigineuse
ils ont la bêtise et jupiter
il a semble-t-il semble-t-il ce serait
lui
il a rendu quasiment invisible son
premier ministre en face et premier
ministre et son gouvernement
sa majorité vous l'avez dit le parlement
tout à coup il y avait plus ça se
passait plus là ça ne se passait plus au
fond qu autour d' emmanuel macron lui
même alors descendant dans la rue allant
au contact mais au fond il n'y a plus qu
emmanuel macron c'est la logique de la
vème république arrivé à son stade final
en tout cas du mandat de cinq ans oui
parce que ça n'aurait pas été possible
du temps où le président était là pour
sept ans c'est vrai puisque il y avait
des connexions marquée entre la majorité
parlementaire dont le premier ministre
étaient supposés émaner et le président
de la république il ya une conque il
voit d'ailleurs que cette réforme du
quinquennat en réalité changer la
constitution elle n'a pas été simplement
une micro mesures qui étaient destinés
dans l'esprit de ses promoteurs à éviter
les cohabitations elle a changé de
nature complètement la nature des
institutions et emmanuel macron c'est a
été happée en quelque sorte par set
break et on lui en donne une version
presque caricatural parce que on se
demande même s'il ya encore un
gouvernement par voie d'eau tellement on
est suspendu à sa parole alors on peut
comprendre au départ et c'est
intéressant du point de vue de sa
philosophie du pouvoir pourquoi il en
est arrivé là il était élu sur une
promesse d'horizontalité vous le
rappeliez très justement et puis une
fois élu il faut marquer quand même
qu'il est président il a peur qu'on ne
prenne pas au sérieux en tant que
président caser les jeunes voir si les
jeunes parce qu'il n'a pas d'expérience
politique prolongée n'a jamais été élu
il n'a jamais été élu non je dis
attention dans son le cercle étroit des
collaborateurs du pouvoir il faut
marquer de l'altitude ça donne la
cérémonie d'intronisation du louvre avec
sa grandiloquence où il s'agit de
d'incarner une sorte d'altitude sur fond
des palais des rois de france
mais c'était assez réussis ça il est
maintenant en termes de mise en scène
c'est réussi mais même il a l'air d'un
président et la mélodie temps voulu dans
son tout à fait non seulement il a l'air
d'un président mais c'est un des plus
présentable en tant que président que
nous ayons eu depuis longtemps
quand je parle de présentable juge pas
du fond mais il a tout à fait l'air d'un
président mais le en même temps n'a pas
marché c'est qu'il fallait faire
coïncider cette promesse
d'horizontalité initial avec la
verticalité jupitérienne et on à
linverse c'est-à-dire un président
horizontal qui est le seul à exister
dans le paysage politique on croyait que
l'horizontale c'était un peu tout le
monde et puis d'autre part une
verticalité qui n'en est pas une puisque
les deux vins bavardage permanence et le
président de la république dont les
oeuvres complètes occuperont 50 volume
dans les bibliothèques
le jour où une éventuelle ou on l'est
recueillera on n'a jamais vu à jupiter
aussi interventionniste et aussi loquace
alors que ça devait être une parole qui
tombe pour trancher du haut de l'olympe
on est sur la place du village avec
attroupement autour fait le contraire il
est il est vertical pour est horizontale
et horizontale 100m vertical on ne
comprend plus il à brouiller
complètement la place du président mais
on dirait que la leçon principale que
vous tirez de l'échec puisque c'est
comme ça que vous le voyez des manuels
macron c'est qu'au fond on n'échappe pas
à la politique professionnelle
au fond il a voulu introduire la société
civile et l'a voulue au fond que les
amateurs s'en mêle il est il s'est
présenté lui-même comme un amateur au
fond que quelqu'un qui avait été
ministre mais qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'expérience politique au sens
politicien du terme il a fait rentrer à
l'assemblée nationale des gens de la
société civile
au fond vous qui vous dites mais les
amateurs sont moins bons que les
professionnels les amateurs se
comportent comme des professionnels
d'abord alors qu'ils pourraient exciper
de leur statut d'amateur donc pour créer
un nouveau genre de politique non il
épouse le rôle et ils font moins bien
que les professionnels
le gain est modeste
et ben le maquereau n'en est pas
responsable de fo il est le produit de
plusieurs années on parlait de la
réduction du mandat à cinq ans c'était
une manière aussi de limiter le pouvoir
du président de la république
on a réduit on à limiter le cumul des
mandats y compris le cumul des mandats
dans le temps on a tout fait pour que ce
ne soit plus un métier la politique à
l'enfant ya une macro on a hérité de
tout ça et ça montre d'après ce que vous
dites que c'était une erreur oui je le
crois je le crois et j'avoue que c'est
pour moi une remise en question profonde
parce que j'avais tout de même
l'impression qu'un peu de politiques
d'amateurs ferez du bien un système trop
professionnalisé mais en réalité et il
fallait changer la politique
professionnelle mais lui garder son
caractère professionnel car c'est
vraiment une tâche qui ne s'improvise
pas et je dirais plus que jamais
aujourd'hui face à la complexité des
attentes des gens et face à la
difficulté de tenir un discours qui
suscite l'attention des citoyens au fond
emmanuel macron tel qu'il est avec les
ambitions qu'il avait mais avec un
véritable parti à l'ancienne
derrière lui vous pensez qu'il aurait
peut-être réussi je pense qu'il aurait
fait beaucoup mieux oui je vous réussi
ça il ya une inconnue je ne me risquerai
pas à trancher mais je pense qu'il
aurait fait beaucoup mieux parce qu'il
aurait d'abord permis de mieux
comprendre sa politique auprès des
français qui dans un premier temps on
voit bien ce qui s'est passé éberlué par
la nouveauté de l'expérience qui était
remarquable donc
observateurs plutôt plutôt sympathique
pourquoi pas avec après ce qu'on avait
vu on était prêts coût de concessions
l'offre était de ce point de vue la
basse il pouvait se permettre beaucoup
de choses puisque il avait pour lui
l'avantagé de faire autre chose bon donc
que ça pouvait pas être pire très chaud
comme disait la sagesse
et bien
l'amateurisme a perdu alors qu'il ya des
vrais professionnels lui aurait permis
probablement de concilier mieux
l'ambition nouvelle qui voulait incarner
et la régularité de l'action publique
est indispensable finalement et que des
politiciens professionnels savent mieux
observer que les amateurs qui imitent
les professionnels en n'étant pas
capable de d'aller jusqu'au bout de leur
exemple la ''refondation'' de l'europe
n'a pas eu lieu
c'était une des une des ambitions des
manuels macron c'était le point qui pour
moi était douteux depuis le départ
j'étais plutôt
favorable
au moins c'est une expérience originale
on va et donnons la prime à l'innovation
ça me et mais la refondation de l'europe
l'a d'emblée pour quelqu'un qui suit un
peu l'actualité ça paraissait pas très
probable surtout que d'autres c'est
essayer renégocier les traités enfin
tous les candidats à chaque élection
présidentielle ressasse ce programme oui
avec la nuance importante à apporter
c'est que emmanuel macron placer la
barre beaucoup plus haut précisément il
avait tiré acte du fait que les
promesses de renégociation et que tu as
échoué systématiquement lui parlait
carrément beaucoup d'aller beaucoup plus
loin de renouer avec l'inspiration
première de la construction européenne
qu est une idée française en proposant
une refondation de cette construction ce
qui aller beaucoup plus loin que de
renégocier simplement quelques
dispositions un peu problématique pour
nous mais bon il était manifeste que
c'est le point sur lequel il aurait
vraiment beaucoup de difficultés s'il ya
une chose à laquelle je ne croyais pas
du tout c'était celle-là mais la réalité
a dépassé mais espère pour si la
recherche
de compétitivité a été d'après ce que
vous dites
mené de façon brutale injuste
maladroite
essentiellement maladroite toutes les
idées n'étaient pas mauvaises en soi il
ya des standards internationaux que les
gouvernements précédents n'avaient pas
osé introduire et qui s'imposent mais
qui appelle à une explication de ce
qu'on fait beaucoup plus poussée et par
exemple le mesures fiscales comme la
flat tax comme on dit sur les capitaux
mouvements de capitaux
pourquoi pas mais il faut dire pourquoi
on le fait et beaucoup mieux qu ils
l'ont fait et surtout il faut expliquer
et pas seulement expliqué mes données en
même temps en même temps oui le en même
temps c'est de la rhétorique parce qu'on
n'a pas vu non beaucoup de mesures
prises par emmanuel macron des gages
d'efficacité
du point de vue de l'intérêt des
salariés français par exemple et du
point de vue du bien collectif
c'est-à-dire de l'efficacité de
l'économie elle est là et il a bénéficié
plutôt d'une conjoncture faste qui fait
qu'on n'a pas vu mais c'est resté
incompréhensible pour les français
notre capacité d' influence au niveau
international est resté au niveau où
où elle était
oui on a eu le sentiment là ça a été le
coup de maître initiale des manuels
mâcon qui a crédibilisé sa politique
c'est les grands de ce monde chez nous
poutine trump il a enclenché une sorte
de dynamique des influences qui pouvait
produire des résultats et qui s'est
révélé très faible et il veut dit-il
finale il faut l'analyser en comparaison
avec ce qui s'était passé sous françois
hollande d'après ce que vous dit
françois hollande sur le plan
international était quasiment inexistant
mais ça ne m'intéressait pas tout
simplement il était contraint videmment
puisqu'un président et dans la machine
mais lui ce qu'il s'était la gestion des
son parti qui était sa préoccupation
prioritaire c'est juste qui fait corps
en effet là on la france n'existait plus
on a eu le sentiment que la france avec
emmanuel macron allait exister de
nouveau sur le plan international elle a
existé verbalement il s'est beaucoup
et d'ailleurs comme il a un propos en
général original il faut lui accorder sa
on les écoute avec intérêt il a un effet
d'image sensationnel et puis derrière on
regarde ce qui se passe rien parce que
ce qui est remarquable par exemple dans
notre rapport avec l'allemagne le que
d'autres voisins immédiats c'est là
toutes ces propositions sont accueillis
par un silence poli ou des réserves on
doit on verra peut-être et finalement il
ne se passe rien mais et même s'il a
brillé en effet d'image est ce que la
france est capable de mieux aujourd'hui
vous vous en parler longuement dans
votre livre on a encore un concierge au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu mais vous
avez l'air de dire qu'on ne mérite plus
c'est le jugement du nom de surdoué fait
que répercuter une appréciation qui est
assez répandu même les allemands ont eu
de temps en temps des velléités de nous
signaler que peut-être il faudrait le
rendre du faudrait évoluer dans un sens
plus mutualiste est lourd au moins
vis-à-vis des européens donc en effet
moins de 1% de la population mondiale et
une économie certes toujours dans le
peloton de tête mais en déclin comment
voulez vous que nous ayons une force de
persuasion internationale significative
et terriblement vu avec l'épidémie de
coville ou milito fonds l'administration
l'état et et est un peu dépassée on va
dire ça comme ça l'administration est
complètement dépassé au fond il ya que
le ministère des finances qui font qu'on
voit qu'on a de bons restes whisky mais
mon câble voilà le médecin des finances
a très bien fonctionné précis bercy
s'est montré à la hauteur de la
situation mais c'est tout ce qui reste
de france
parce que il là on entre dans le vif du
sujet précisément ces modèles qu'on a
importé de gré ou de force sous
influence européenne et par une espèce
de volonté de nos élites de faire comme
les autres ont des membres et notre
système de commandement politique
décentralisation d'un côté
transformation de l'état avec un système
d' agences anarchique qui dans la crise
de qu'ovide a montré son inefficacité
on appela industrielle on était bas on a
fait le choix de la façon de choix au
cours des années précédentes qui ont
fait qu'on n'était même plus capable de
fabriquer des masques je nie avec les
masques il ya beaucoup de choses dont on
s'est aperçu qu'on ne sait pas quand
même le doliprane
qui ne paraît pas une une entité
critiques d'une grande complexité qui on
aurait peut-être pu garder mais non on
ya eu à dépouillement et c'est ça que
les français ont perçu et le
déclassement finale est arrivé quand on
s'est aperçu qu'on était le seul pays
membre du conseil de sécurité incapable
de développer un vaccin il ya eu une
sorte de prix conscient du déclassement
français qui un déclassement à la fois
objectif et subjectif c'est à dire qui
et qui prend à revers l'image que les
français continuaient à se faire de même
et qui d'antibes où il on a dû admettre
qu'il est qu'elle était très surestimé
par rapport à la réalité mais en même
temps j'allais dire nous sommes
condamnés à la présidentielle de 2000 22
qui peut battre emmanuel macron à
première vue personnes et le côté
remarquable mais vraiment l'accident
historique sans précédent dans les
annales c'est que nous avons à faire un
président qui a changé d'électorat en
cours de route et de fonction il était
l'homme du mouvement la rupture de la
révolution de la transformation il est
devenu le garant de la continuité et il
était il a été lui essentiellement par
des voix de gauche
il son électorat et du côté de
l'establishement de droite de
l'establishment social de droite parce
qu'il est effectivement celui avec
lequel on sait qu'on peut continuer en
gros comme par devant certes avec un peu
de ma ram de désordre mais enfin au
total on continue que vous sans toucher
aux équilibres du pays et il était
l'homme du mouvement de la disruption
comme on dit aujourd'hui et finalement
c'est le l'homme de l'ordre et aucun
concurrent n'est capable de le compte de
le mettre véritablement difficulté sur
les terrains elle sur le terrain
électoral c'est tout à fait étonnant je
crois que le le le sentiment que ça
n'était pas du tout ce qu'on attendait
aujourd'hui assez inquiet dans la
procréation finalement on va continuer
contre m marine le pen pour vous ne pas
plus de chance en 2022 qu'en 2017 a
priori je ne pense pas
je sais si je puis dire la perdante
professionnels donc pourquoi changer une
perdante qui perd c'est très bien tout
le temps arrange tout le monde d'une
certaine façon la france est un drôle de
pays c'est le pays de la révolution et
c'est le pays un des pays les plus c'est
le pays de la révolution parce que c'est
un des pays les plus conservateurs qui
soir ce qui se comprend très bien si on
conserve absolument au bout d'un moment
la rupture survient au lieu d'évoluer
tranquillement donc de ce point de vue
là
emmanuel macron a toutes les chances
parce que malgré tout marine le pen même
si elle est très familiarisés dans le
paysage et si elle a beaucoup changé son
discours celle aventure on ne sait pas
où on va avec elle au moins avec macron
les gènes conservateur du pays dorment
tranquilles on sait où on va et eric
zemmour ah ça c'est la grande inconnue
de cette nouvelle équation politique il
faut dire qu'il a réussi quelque chose
d'invraisemblable que personne
absolument n'anticipait emmanuel macron
c'était une grande surprise lui aussi
mais eric zemmour c'est la surprise au
carré et c'est une surprise qui d'une
certaine manière prolongée l'effet
macron c'est à dire on croyait que
macron était la rupture et ben non ce
n'était pas lui mais il y avait des
mouvements profonds
comme macron a détruit le système des
partis en place on peut le dire
carrément comme ça il ya un vide qui
kidnappent ou non la scène politique
offre tout un théâtre pour des gens qui
ont une fibre plus d'un coup moi c'est
sur le plan psychologique que la
métamorphose des 22 d'eric zemmour qui
me surprend le plus parce que on le
voyait vraiment pas comme un candidat à
la présidentielle c'était le pool le
pamphlétaire le chroniqueur vedette mais
un homme de médias et donc il a une
crédibilité politique acquise en
quelques semaines
si on aime bien lu votre livre on se dit
eric zemmour
admettons qui devient président demain
c'est encore pire qu'avec emmanuel
macron c'est qu'il n'a pas de parti
aucun relais dans le pays enfin deux
sens des relais au sens où vous
l'entendez vous
on sait même pas s'il aurait des
candidats aux législatives
enfin ça c'est perdu d'avancé ça paraît
en effet la halle à celle aventure au
carré de vivre par refonder l'europe
valais il est dans quelque chose de bien
plus radicale radicale même et donc il y
le et en même temps il est dans la ligne
dans la brèche ouverte par emmanuel
macron parce que lui c'est pour de bon
la société civile on ad on emmanuel
macron a dit à la société civile on va
vous rendre le pouvoir et bien chiche
eric zemmour devient le candidat de la
société civile ou d'une partie d'entre
elles évidemment qu'est-ce qu'on est
dans un cadre contradictoires
et
la droite et la gauche enfin la droite
et la gauche au sens où on l'entendait
vous l'entendiez il ya 30 ans dont dans
votre d'entre l'article qui avait paru
dans les lieux de mémoire je parle du
livre que vous venez de de ressortir
chez gallimard la droite et la gauche
donc le grand parti de droite et le
grand parti de gauche ils n'ont plus
aucune chance où ils pourraient se
rétablir
à court terme aucune chance à moyen
terme
au fil des expériences et de capacité de
tirer les sens parce que ce qui est
assez étonnant là non pas sur le fond
mais conjoncturellement avec les parties
telles conditions c'est qu'ils sont
tétanisés et à un degré stupéfiants
parce qu'ils ont même pas l'air de
réfléchir sur les raisons de leur
abaissement plus jeu ça c'est du monde
la russie de l'inédit en général quand
on échoue on se dit pourquoi avons-nous
échoué eh bien non nous avons échoué
continueront parce que finalement c'est
la fois du succès c'est un confrère leur
comportement est incompréhensible et
donc à court terme mais ça n'empêche pas
que les au delà des partis les la grille
de lecture de la gauche et de la droite
continue de fonctionner la preuve en est
c'est que dès que vous écrivez sur mac
rond la première question qui vous est
posée par tout le monde c est ce que
finalement il est bon qu est-ce qu il
est de droite donc il ya bien besoin de
situer ce partage quelque part il ya
même s'il ne fonctionne plus du point de
vue du système politique il ya
l'écologie aussi qui est là les
généralement les écologistes font une
percée aux européennes immédiatement
tous les journalistes excitant disant ça
y est c'est la troisième force et puis
ça s'écroule généralement pour toutes
les autres élections ne sais pas ce
qu'il adviendra cette voie ici mais
l'écologie qu'il se veut justement ni de
droite ni de gauche qui se veut au
dessus et qui en même temps
prospères sur la peur que nous pouvons
avoir de la crise environnementale la
crise environnementale est une réalité
alors quand on il faut pas raisonner sur
l'écologie simplement dans le cadre
français faut prendre au moins le cadre
européen et on s'aperçoit que les partis
écologistes sont extrêmement divers
l'écologie allemand pour prendre
l'exemple principal c'est une écologie
très centriste et qui a participé à
nombre de gouvernements au niveau local
en tout cas il va probablement participé
aux 20 niveaux élevés
au prochain gouvernement allemand le
l'écologie française elle est carrément
c'est une extrême gauche recycler
pour laquelle la cause écologique et le
recyclage de l'anticapitalisme c'est
assez clair pour tout le monde mais en
fait sur le fond
l'explication de cette difficulté à
passer en politique de l'écologie
singulièrement en france c'est qu'en
réalité le clivage gauche-droite
traverse l'écologie il ya une écologie
de gauche précisément anticapitaliste
mais est donc tous en éventuellement
caricaturalement le bouchon jusqu'à
renier la technologie moderne dont un
jeu
nous avons eu des propos assez
extraordinaire nous on nous expliquait
qu'il fallait préférer une sorcière
jetant des sorts à des ingénieurs qui
construisent des eps
conceptuellement ça ouvre un peu de
vertige tout de même et puis d'autre
part il ya eu au contraire une écologie
de droite si je puis dire qui
c'est confiance à la technologie pour
apporter des réponses et qu'il considère
qu'il est qu'on peut parfaitement
imaginer une société capitaliste qui
soit une société écologique ce temps que
ce temps que ce clivage ne sera pas
réglé je pense que les écologistes au
fond n'auront pas le discours qui leur
permet de figurer au niveau des choix
nationaux véritable aujourd'hui on voit
bien dans toute la classe politique
la peur d gilet jaune
comme si ça pouvait recommencer d'un
instant à l'autre et ça pourrait vous
pensez ça pourrait savourer parce que je
pense que il ya eu le manuel macron
réussi parce que c'est un showman de
première classe il faut bien le dire il
aurait pu faire carrière au cinéma
ne fait pas une idée pas celle là il a
réussi à calmer le jeu après l'épisode
et gilet jaune d'abord par épuisement
gilet jaune par des voix mais aussi en
partie du mouvement et puis par capacité
de montrer de refus née d'une part le
son offre politique aux préoccupations
des gens montrant qu'il était très au
courant artificiellement ou réellement
c'est un autre problème et en
remobilisant la base notabiliaires qui
lui fait défaut aux étudiants il a
réussi leur établissement mais
maintenant bon le calme est revenu mais
le redémarrage peut survenir à tout
instant il ya en ce moment il est
question par exemple de quelque chose
qui trouble beaucoup dans la france
automobilistes c'est l'interdiction de
la partie
signalement des forces de police de
l'application utilisée par tous les
chauffeurs qui et wej situés
signalent les
radars
si ça c'est le genre de menu qui peuvent
demain provoquer une expand et gilet
jaune que vous analysez encore une fois
très très bien dans dans votre livre
souffre aussi de sa méfiance
terrible pour tout ce qui est
hiérarchisé présentant pour eux dès
qu'on accède à une responsabilité on
risque d'être corrompu par cette
responsabilité ça les empêche de
s'organiser et d'une certaine manière
c'est à les condamne ces des
protestataires pur gilet jaune et ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est de voir le
mélange de facteurs qui interviennent
dans ce mouvement ou des chiffres
vraiment de manière limpide les
difficultés et des contradictions de
notre société parce que c'est un
mouvement de protestation politique mais
que en même qui revendiquent eux la
démocratie directe le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne mais avec un même
temps un individualisme radical qu'il
fait que la politique étant
l'organisation du collectif il ya une
impossibilité de passer au niveau
politique c'est une un mouvement auto
contradictoires d'une certaine façon
dans sa façon de fonctionner et
évidemment mais ça n'empêche pas d'être
une menace redoutable parce qu'il a un
effet non pas constructif de proposer
une alternative mais un effet de
délégitimation de tous les pouvoirs en
place qui est absolument radicales merci
marcel gauchet de va passer toute cette
émission avec nous je rappelle vos deux
livres qui viennent de sortir la droite
et la gauche histoire et destin ça vient
de paraître chez gallimard et macron les
leçons d'un échec c'est paru chez stock
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]